so the the infinite game is not the
absence of finite games
um you can absolutely have arbitrary
goals and remember most of the financial
goals we set a few people sat in a room
and said what do we want our annual goal
to be and somebody says let's make it
this number and somebody goes no let's
make it this number and that becomes the
number right there's nothing wrong with
that absolutely nothing in fact it's
necessary human beings are very tangibly
driven animals we like counting things
it's actually important can you imagine
uh running a marathon without mile
markers it would actually be unnerving
so metrics help us measure speed and
distance which is very very important
um but we have to remember that when we
hit a metric or don't hit a metric the
game has not been won or lost
they're markers right and and that's the
important part so stop thinking we have
to stop thinking about business like a
race or a game and start thinking of it
like a lifestyle so for example I want
to be healthy right so there are many
things I have to do to be healthy I have
to eat right I have to exercise I have
to you know get enough sleep I have to
nourish my personal relationships
there's probably 15 or 20 other things
can't do all of those things well all
the time it's a striving same in
business we have you know we have
product we have marketing we have sales
we have leadership can't do them all
right all the time it's a striving but
we can set arbitrary goals like I want
to lose x amount of weight by X date
right and every day I'm going to stand
on the scale some days I'll feel good
and some days I'll feel bad and when I
hit my goal I'm excited
um but the problem is I have to keep
exercising for the rest of my life like
it hasn't ended simply because I hit a
goal and that's important to recognize
but what I find more interesting is what
happens if you miss the goal and the
answer is
nothing
nothing happens in fact very often we
just miscalculated the the time it'll
take to achieve it so if you're doing
all the right things and you you see the
trend data is is on path
and you just lose that weight in a month
later or two months later
okay you're healthier now even missing
the goal than you were before
the the bad news the where it gets
dangerous is when we're so obsessed with
that goal that I'll starve myself and
stop drinking water to hit the goal and
I'm actually unhealthy and companies do
that so the goals are good and
celebrating the wins are great and there
are wins that's fantastic but we have to
remember that if we miss the goal the
question is what's the trend data like
are we a healthy company are we taking
care of each other and I'll just go back
a few years ago
um
uh uh Ginny remedy uh
IBM missed its numbers
and Ginny Romney made an internal video
which of course leaked made an internal
video
that was spread out set up to the entire
IBM that basically
[ __ ] all over the sales team publicly
and I remember talking to somebody at
IBM and I'm like What's with that video
and they're like oh so glad I'm not in
sales right and basically berated them
for missing the numbers this was the
first time IBM had missed its numbers
the first quarter in 69 quarters
and the CEO's response was to berate a
team the direct entire division right
after 69 quarters they missed their
first one guess what happened after that
berating the team and what happened to
the culture and guess how many times
they missed it after that it continued
in other words it's fine it's fine to
miss it it's a game it's a long game so
I think that's where we get confused
which is we become obsessed with we
missed our numbers once we're we're
doing fantastic
you know so I think that's what it's
just about keeping things in perspective
that's why the infinite mindset helps
it's just about perspective